buongiorno a tutti io sono giorgio 23
anni sono nato a lodi e da circa due
anni mi occupo di là di città aperta in
qualità di tutor a un moderatore
facilitatore del gruppo in questi giorni
ma anche prima stavo pensando di fronte
a tutte le domande che mi sono state
sottoposte cos'era di città aperta cosa
fate sembrate un gruppo e se dovessi
riassumere in tre parole che sanno di
città aperta mi verrebbe da dire è un
progetto che investe sui giovani che di
valorizza soprattutto in responsabilizza
e con giovani intendo italiani seconde
generazioni stranieri appena arrivati
anche che masticano un po di italiano e
questo penso che se il valore aggiunto
di quello che adesso andrò a spiegarvi
mia figlia
partiamo quindi dal capire chi forma la
di città aperta e come è nato come è
nato il progetto
innanzitutto partire proprio dal dove è
nato da chi idea insomma è partito il
tutto c'è stato a lodi una serie di
progetti che includevano le seconde
generazioni l'intercultura all'interno
delle scuole delle scuole superiori
soprattutto e dopo diversi anni però è
nata l'esigenza proprio di dire ok
spacchiamo c dal contesto prettamente
scolastico e includiamo anche altre
persone altre giovani e soprattutto
quelli magari già lavorano o non
lavorano nè studiano che in questo
momento in italia sempre sono sempre più
in aumento quindi all'interno di questo
gruppo e ci sono diverse realtà da
appartenenze sociali appunto anche
culturali e lavorative o studentesche
nostro obiettivo quindi è puntare sui
giovani come risorsa per la cittadinanza
non solamente con un peso sia da dare il
contentino una volta ogni tanto ma
cercare di investire dove in un contesto
italiano purtroppo poco si sta facendo
da diversi anni e quindi si cerca anche
di dare una speranza soprattutto ha nei
giovani è sempre nel promuovere e
valorizzare le seconde generazioni
l'anno scorso il progetto è nato è nato
l'anno scorso comprendeva un gruppo di
ragazzi e ragazze residenti nella
provincia di lodi dai 16 ai 19 anni
mentre quest'anno siamo aggiunto ma la
seconda edizione abbiamo incrementato il
numero perché molta gente molte persone
rimasta anche interessate dal progetto
colpite ha deciso di proseguire con noi
ormai siamo circa 25 anche trenta
ragazzi e ragazze come dicevo prima non
tutti i residenti
la città di lodi ma anche nei dintorni e
soprattutto alcuni che studiano
diciamo stanno cercando stai cercando
lavoro il percorso formativo quale è
stato l'anno scorso siamo partiti da da
formare il gruppo di persone che si
trovava seduta attorno a un tavolo in
bellissima location e dal dire ok chi
siamo noi perché siamo qui e ben
cominciato attraverso analisi proprio
dall io dal mio personale quindi chi
sono le mie radici le mie esperienze
la mia vita passando poi a una dinamica
più di rapporto con l'altro
quindi anche è lo stereotipo il rapporto
con i miei compagni di scuola con gli
amici per poi arrivare a una definizione
di intercultura negoziate condiviso da
tutti noi
quindi proprio dal io l'altro e
l'intercultura facendo ciò siamo
arrivati anche a produrre cartelloni
video un sacco di prodotti concreti che
abbiamo poi condiviso con la
cittadinanza e diciamo la nostra
community che piano piano si stava
creando quest'anno invece ben deciso di
puntare un pochettino più in alto quindi
dall'inter cultura siamo passati anche
una sorta di laboratorio sulla questione
dei generi quindi il uomo donna e anche
tutte le diverse declinazioni c'è la
categoria lgbt che a molti anche anche
dino era completamente sconosciuta
c'erano sai c'è un sacco di
incomprensioni di anche di ignoranza e
quindi abbiamo fatto un percorso e
proprio per cercare di fare chiarezza e
capirne di più per poi poter neanche
discutere
cosa cosa abbiamo in mente un'idea di
città a terra che è promuovere le
seconde generazioni i giovani come un
importante della cittadinanza ma
attraverso quali canali ci sono sempre
dati l'obiettivo di poter comunicare
l'intercultura di poter comunicare i
nostri laboratori e di formare proprio
un gruppo è attivo che propone essere le
attività anche agli altri giovani della
città della città di lodi e non solo e
quindi attraverso il web quindi i social
network da facebook a twitter abbiamo
creato gli account e anche un sito
internet
abbiamo cominciato a dire ok ci siamo ci
troviamo e bello discutere ma da
produrre qualcosa che siano filmati
interviste lettere ai giornali e prima
ha incominciato a fare anche dei piccoli
dei piccoli delle piccole redazioni
diversi filmati con approfondimenti di
teoria della comunicazione di come una
videocamera come usare una macchina
fotografica e siamo passati anche poi
alla relazionarci con le realtà locali
ovvio il nome lodi città aperta dal
senso proprio di di apertura verso
l'altro
partendo proprio dalle realtà che già
esistono nel nostro territorio
personalmente vedo tantissime realtà
locali anche nazionali che però fanno
fatica a mettersi in rete con le altre e
in questo caso ci stiamo riuscendo e
stiamo cercando di aprirci di aprirci
sempre di più nel fare tutto questo
stiamo anche cercando di valorizzare i
luoghi dell'intercultura a lodi nel
lodigiano
quindi tutti quei posti che sono sempre
stati considerati magari un post del
vanoi antini giocata giocherà kart dove
vanno
altre persone stanno cercando di
rivalorizzare naturalmente e quindi
stanno cercando anche di mappare la
nostra città e tutto il lodigiano
definendo proprio i luoghi
dell'intercultura attraverso la
costruzione ad esempio una casa del
quartiere di unci ag è già esiste o
anche di un teatrino dell'informagiovani
quindi anche di fare rete far conoscere
anche i ragazzi di lodi non solo che ad
oggi ci sono tanti posti da poter
utilizzare
detto questo
penso che adesso shira vi spiegherà un
po meglio il laboratorio che è stato
fatto e vi ringrazio tutti si sente
allora io sono sceglierà l'altra 9 anni
e faccio appunto parte di lodi città
aperta che giorgio ha già spiegato cos'è
detto oggi io sono qui per presentare la
mia esperienza come membro interno del
gruppo e cosa significa la di città
aperta per le seconde generazioni io
sono di origine tunisina sono qui da
quando avevo quattro anni quindi mi
definisco una ragazza di seconda
generazione parlo benissimo italiano e
spesso le seconde generazioni si trovano
infine con fra due culture e non sanno
devono scegliere ma non non siamo
costretti a scegliere
certe volte sentirsi in bilico è come
sentirsi utili di nessuno e di città
aperta dalla possibilità di integrare
queste due culture e essere accettati
per ciò che siamo
le seconde generazioni io grazie niente
io faccio appunto parte di questo
progetto da due anni
l'anno scorso siamo partiti un po senza
sapere dove sarebbe andato a finire
questo progetto siamo eravamo in
quindici ragazzi e pensavamo che fosse
solo un progetto scolastico poi si è
scoperto invece che è stato l'estensione
non è sempre la semplice estensione di
un progetto scolastico ma si sono creati
dei veri e propri rapporti di amicizia
io con alcune ragazze ci riesco anche a
mangiare se usciamo la sera ed è
diventato veramente un rapporto
importante ed è bello vedere che così
tante culture si possono unire anche
nelle differenze di opinioni perché come
ha detto lui ci sono stati davvero delle
grandissime litigate per opinioni
differenti però c'è stato il rispetto il
rispetto delle idee quest'anno invece
stiamo lavorando
sul su tre parole principali cioè c'è
stato un percorso di autobiografia come
cia stato l'anno scorso per far
conoscere un po il gruppo e poi abbiamo
parlato di di tre parole principali
sesso genere e orientamento sessuale e
abbiamo definito un po cos'erano queste
tre parole e cosa la società si aspetta
dai membri dalle persone che vengono
rinnegati in queste tre parole e si è
scoperto si sono scoperte tante cose
tante cose che non si sapevano che
magari si davano per scontati o si
ignoravano
e da questo da queste tre domande da
queste tre parole sono uscite un po di
domande attraverso un lavoro di gruppi
sia arrivato ad avere quattro domande
principali a cui noi risponderemo con un
video risposta che presenteremo poi alla
città di lodi e
niente adesso stiamo lavorando per
questo video e speriamo che venga bene
niente io oggi sono un po emozionata si
vede e volevo lasciarvi con un pensiero
che ho scritto oggi mentre venivo in
treno spero che vi piaccia
ok
allora
passiamo la vita come passeggeri
distratti dove treno in corsa che
guardando fuori dalla panatta finestra
vedono solo forme stereotipate du
lontano paesaggio l'era group ramon
categorie
andiamo avanti e andiamo avanti lo
facciamo sempre lo facciamo con tutto
anche con le persone quello è un
ballerino di sicuro è gay
quello a hera spa è un drogato lei al
velo e una terrorista raggruppiamo le
persone che mosè fossero forme
stereotipate dietro un appannata
finestra senza renderci conto di essere
tutte pedine di una stessa scacchiera
bisognerebbe andare oltre oltre
l'aspetto fisico li atteggiamento li
orientamento alla provenienza lo di
città aperta fa questo lo di città
aperta e l'esperienza di vivere
condivide condividere e con vivere
un'esperienza con chi con te non ha
niente in comune se non è il fatto di
essere una persona